So if you would just start by introducing yourself, just let us know your name and the date
date and where we got, I know.
Okay.
I'm Christopher Matthews.
Today is September 2nd, 2011, and we're in the Valley Memorial Library.
Okay.
So, just know where you were born and what you were up.
I was born in 1937 in New York City, and my father was about to start a medical practice
in the Grinchport, Connecticut, so we moved from New York very early.
He was stationed with the Navy during the war on a variety of places, and moved to Seattle
in 1944, and the family moved with him.
After the war, my family moved back to Connecticut again, but after three years they realized
they'd made a big mistake leaving the West Coast, so we moved to Olympia in 1949, and
that's what I consider my hometown.
What was some of your hobbies when you were growing up?
Well, I was pretty interested in science, obviously.
I had a chemistry set, and my friends and I used to make rockets and fire them off.
And I became interested in birding a nature study because my grandfather was a professional
ornithologist who was cured of birds at the American Museum of Natural History in New
York, so we had, we were very much exposed to natural history all my life, and that's
kept on.
What was the president of the Audubon Society of Corvallis for three years?
So there was a strong family influence in the science, and I'm trying to understand where
that early interest in science came from, right?
Right.
Well, my grandfather of course was an ornithologist, and a very broadly based biologist.
My father was a physician, and his father was a surgeon, so there wasn't, well, let's
say there was both medical and scientific achievement in our background, and people
who are just natural, I guess, for me to have a career in science, although I did consider
medicine pretty strongly at various times.
My mother?
She has a degree from Vassar in English and actually dramatic production, and she never
got involved in science, but she obviously encouraged what my brother and my sisters, and
I did.
My brother ended up as a wildlife biologist and retired a few years ago from the University
of Washington faculty in the College of Fisheries.
My sisters are all younger, and they, two of them finished college, but they finished
in their thirties.
My parents went through a fairly messy divorce when my sisters were teenagers, and I think
this kept them from being motivated to go through college, but they were all very bright
and they went back.
At a cheap quite a lot, actually, my youngest sister, among other things, has published
three books, one of which was described her experience as the winner of the Pillsbury
Bake Off in 1998, with a $1 million prize.
It's a very readable book.
Very interesting.
So outside of your family, were there other scientific mentors or influences in your life
as a child?
I guess so, I hadn't thought very much about that, but not so much toward the hard science.
In fact, the chemistry course that I took in high school is probably my least favorite
course, although the teacher, Mr. Gaines, was my merit badge counselor when I got the chemistry
merit badge in Boy Scout.
This is my freshman year in high school, and he told me I shouldn't try for it, so I was
a junior and had taken chemistry, and he helped me through it.
But he wasn't a very good teacher, and the botany teacher, Mr. Burke, also, and the physics
teacher, Mr. Keller, none of them I thought were particularly good teachers, but there was
enough interest in what I was doing, and that I guess that provided some motivation.
So scouting was something you were involved in?
Yes.
When we moved to Olympia, we lived in the right in town, actually, about two blocks from
the state capital building, and it was very easy to be in Boy Scouts, and my parents bought
some waterfront land about seven miles out of town, and we moved there to a house that
they built in my freshman year, and it became much more difficult to be involved in scouting
after that.
So, although I always wanted to be an ego scout, I just drifted out of it.
How would you characterize the rest of your high school experience?
That's an interesting question, too.
I had to skip the second grade, so I was younger and smaller than most of my classmates, and
it took me a while to catch up socially, but I worked pretty hard at it, and ended up
with a very nice group of friends.
I thought that educationally the high school experience was pretty mediocre, but maybe
I was too hard on it.
I worked pretty hard, and obviously did pretty well.
My daughter managed to make it through Corvallis High in three years, and when I thought back
on my high school experience, maybe that would have been good, but then I would have been
two years ahead, and the catching up socially would have been that much more difficult.
Any sports in the end?
I've never been very athletic, but I've enjoyed doing things, I've skied across country
skied, and I jog regularly, and you wouldn't call that athletics, but it's keeping in shape.
Played a little tennis, but it never was very good as much of anything in a way of sports.
Okay, so after high school, you went to Reed College, how did you decide to go to Reed?
Well, I was reading an article on the Saturday evening post in 1952, my junior year in high
school, and there was an article by Richard Newberger, who later became a senator from Oregon,
and the title of the article was The School for Bright Young Things, and I guess that's
sort of what I perceived myself as, and I'd never heard of Reed College before, even though
we lived just 120 miles away from Portland, and it looked like a pretty exciting place,
and it seemed as though it would be bright for me, and so I applied to Reed, and I applied
to Stanford, and of course, it was accepted both places, and Reed just seemed much more
convenient, and it was more affordable, quite a distinction between the two alternatives,
because our son eventually went to Stanford, so I learned a lot more about it.
Yeah, actually three of us from my graduating class went to Reed, and one of them only
made it two years, the other one who'd been a very strong science student ended up majoring
in philosophy and going to law school, and also becoming an extremely accomplished folk
musician here and his wife basically made their living, so Reed was interesting in terms
of the fact that a lot of people went there moving in one direction and changed directions
completely, or undirected and getting a direction. There was also a very high attrition rate
then, so there were a number of students that went there undirected, and there wasn't much
supervision, and so a number of students had dropped out, and I was one of the ones who
had sort of a vague idea of what I wanted to do, and basically stayed with it.
What was the climate like in the day?
I suppose pretty much like it is today, it was pretty intense intellectually, but the
students knew how to have a good time as well. The academic environment was very strong.
The courses in liberal arts and social science all had a very heavy writing component, so
in the freshman humanities course we had to write a paper every week, and then we had
an individual conference about every paper with the instructor, so anything credit I can
take for my ability to write today, I owe to Reed College, and the science was very strong
also. At that time in the early mid-50s I would say that the science wasn't as strong
as it is currently. Reed, like many of the other high-quality undergraduate colleges,
has really made a push for a stronger research orientation in the science faculty, and although
we were all required to write a thesis when I was a student, I would say the thesis worked
all cutting-edge science, but put it that way. In fact, one of my regrets about Reed
was that I probably took more science than I really needed to, and I should have taken
more courses in liberal arts philosophy and the literature and social sciences than I did,
but I ended up with the interest in a lot of different areas and can learn a lot of things
through my own reading, and that's what College is supposed to be for anyway, I think.
How would you say you're a scientific interest developer than the graduate?
Well, I went there as a chemistry major because of my interest that started with the
weeding about chemistry and playing with chemistry sets and so forth, so it was sort of an
unfocused interest, but at some point I read a science fiction anthology of short stories,
and the stories were grouped by scientific area that the science fiction dealt with, and so
there were two or three stories that were listed under biochemistry. I never heard of biochemistry
before, and I thought, hey, the idea of chemistry that has something to do with biology,
I'm going to have to read these stories and I enjoyed them, and so my junior year,
I took a biochemistry course, and the reading I did, both in class and auto class,
convinced me that this was a pretty exciting area to go into. During my sophomore year,
I'd wrestled with the idea of going to medical school. I had a hard time with organic chemistry,
the first term of it, and the fall term of my sophomore year, and I'd like to tell medical
students or pre-medical students this story. I began to wonder if I was bright enough to go into
science and maybe I should go into medicine instead, but then the second semester of the
main course for majors was quantitative analysis. I did much better, and at the end of the
year I decided I was bright enough to go into science after all.
Was it headway or reading, or maybe when you're in high school, you told me a story about a legend
that you would do very well in college?
I first heard of Linus Pauling, the fall semester of my freshman year in chemistry class
and then there was a student who raised his hand to ask a question, and he said,
oh professor, does what you're talking about have anything to do with the Pauling theory of resonance,
and Professor Lumeur gave me a very respectful answer, and I thought to myself, I've never heard of Pauling,
but I guess I'd better learn something about this guy. Then remarkably enough, within the next two or three
weeks, it was announced that Linus Pauling had won the Nobel Prize in chemistry, so I
realized that this student was a little bit ahead of me in terms of knowing major scientific
themes.
Did you make a letter about a letter you had in there about Pauling?
Right, I guess you and I talked about that a few years ago. You want me to describe that for the
Oregonian published an editorial a day or two after the Nobel Prize was announced.
It was basically congratulations to a native son of Oregon who went on and achieved the
great things, and won the Nobel Prize, but wasn't ashamed about his inaccurate thinking
and his political associations that had led him to have his passport lifted.
And I thought it was pretty inappropriate to bring these political things into
at a time when we should be celebrating this person's intellectual triumph.
And so I wrote my first letter to the editor ever, and at that time Reed College was in
very bad odor in the Portland area because the Velley Committee, which was the House on American
Activities Committee, had toured the country in the spring just before I started college.
And three members of the Reed faculty were interviewed and refused to discuss their
associations, and this made a lot of people think that Reed was full of communist.
So when I wrote the letter to the editor, I used my home address from the
editor, which could be seen as being within the readership area of the Oregonian.
And then I guess I clipped the editorial and my letter and mailed them home to my mother.
And because my grandparents knew the Paulins, my grandfather was a member of the American Philosophical
Society, which Paulin was also my mother mailed this to my grandmother, and my grandmother
mailed it to Paulin. And Paulin eventually sent me a nice short note, which pleased me a great deal.
Paulin's youngest son, Crillon, was a classmate of mine at Reed, and then later on when I was a
graduate student at the University of Washington, and my wife was a graduate student in genetics,
Crillon Paulin was doing his graduate work in genetics also.
So Kate and the Crillon worked in the same lab, and we used to see them socially, fairly frequently.
So somehow or another, I had a fairly close series of relationships with the Paulin family.
That's a heads-on idea about that. Can you reflect on the time with Crillon at all?
I'm sorry? Can you reflect on your time with Crillon at all?
Yeah, he was pretty immature, and he had a great sense of humor, he seemed to enjoy life a lot.
He started as a chemistry major at Reed, and he didn't do very well, so he switched to biology, and it took him five years to graduate.
So he started graduate school at UW a year after I had, and then I think it took him five or six years to finish his PhD.
But he actually published some fairly important papers from his postdoc, and then later on when he was on the faculty at San Francisco State,
as far as I remember right, he was chair of the biology department there for quite a few years.
And so he was always a very likable fellow, and he was on sabbatical here in 1980 and 1981.
He worked with Dick Morita in the microbiology department, and his second wife, K-Paul, I worked in art department as a postdoc with one of my colleagues.
So we reestablished contact, then it was very pleasant.
There was kind of an amusing, this doesn't have anything to do with college era, but during that year that Krell and Pauling was here, I was called upon to be the organizer of the, what used to be the annual biology colloquial, I'm not even sure if that's still held.
So I organized a two-day meeting on the organization and manipulation of genetic information, this is 1981, and we had a party for the speakers and the people were participating.
And President McVicker was at the party and he came up to me, and he said, Chris, I'd like to have you introduce me to winus Pauling Sun.
So I took him over and introduced him to Krell and he backed Krell and into a corner and wouldn't let him out and they were talking there for probably 20 minutes.
I was trying to think of a way that I could rescue Krell, but it didn't work.
So did you have any blinds Pauling?
Yes, probably the first time I met him, he came to Seattle for a lecture and I met him there, so that would have been in 1961 when I was a student.
But then my first month here, I started my employment as chairman of biochemistry and biophysics in January 1978, and one of the first things I learned in my first week on the job was that I had to get ready for sight visit for our department.
Because the legislature in the previous year had made some sort of a budget note or order of some kind that there should be reviews of academic programs that might involve duplication between Oregon State and the U of O.
Although the U of O didn't have a biochemistry department, they had the Institute of Molecular Biology and they had a biology department and a chemistry department.
So chemistry and biochemistry were getting reviewed and Linus Pauling was one of the outside reviewers that was brought in and it was fairly intimidating.
So I had to prepare for a day-long sight visit, I've forgotten who the other reviewers were, and then we had a similar experience.
We were a sight visit as a biology department as well, so I had to organize two sight visits.
I remember the biology sight visit, one of the sight visitors was Herschel Roman, who was professor of genetics at the UW, and he was the one that my wife worked for.
And one of the other sight visitors was a guy named Gordon Lark, who was at Kansas State University who was quite a prominent bacterial geneticist, and when he met with me early in the morning, he said,
how did you move here anyway, and sort of a wondering what the deal was, what was the attraction, because I had a pretty good job at the University of Arizona before I moved here.
And then later in the day, when I met with him again, and they had a chance to talk to a lot of other people and learn about Oregon State.
You don't have to answer him anymore, he said, now I know why you moved here, so I felt pretty good about the decision I had made to move when that happened.
That gets a little bit away from Linus Pauling, but I met him two or three times when he came to the campus, either for the annual award of the Pauling Medal, or for other things, somehow we were brought into contact.
So I probably met him half a dozen times.
Did I ever tell you the story about Pauling on the joke that he told at the Pauling? Do you want to hear that, it gets a little bit out of the chronology.
So the Three North Western sections of the American Accountal Society give the Linus Pauling Medal every year jointly, and there is symposium on a banquet, and the locale moves around from Corvallis to Seattle to Pullman Washington or wherever.
And in the fall of 1979 it was held here, and so Pauling used to come to all these, and after the banquet then he would give a little talk about what he'd been doing during the previous year, these things were always hugely entertaining.
And so the talk that I gave in 1979, and Mrs. Pauling was with him, she was still alive then, he said that he was encountering a lot of skepticism about Vitamin C, and the reporter was interviewing him, and he said, now Professor Pauling, you take Vitamin C, don't you?
Well, of course I do, young man. Well then Sir, do you mind if I ask you a few questions about your state of vigor? No, go right ahead.
Well Sir, can you tell me then please, when did you have your last sexual experience? Well I looked at him and I said why in 1956? And he said, well that's terrible.
And I said, what's so terrible about it? And he looked at his watch and said, it's only 22-10 now.
Okay, well, give me back to your life. So we mentioned that Washington and Nancy Alling, everything Washington's yellow, how do you make this decision to go to the recovery?
Okay, that's a good question too. In the summer of 1957, I went back to visit my grandparents in Long Island, and they were very interested in having me go to graduate school in the East Coast.
So they took me to visit various schools, Harvard and Brown and Johns Hopkins. But one thing that I did, since they lived fairly far out on the island, they'd arranged a visit for me at Brookhaven National Laboratory, and I met with a biochemist there named Robert Steele, and he told me about what he was doing and he said,
I don't know why you're looking at all of these graduate schools in the East Coast when one of the best graduate schools in the country is right out of where you live, and I said, what's that?
And he said, well, the University of Washington, it's a new department, but it's really good. So I figured, well, I guess I'd better look at it.
So I ended up applying to vertically Johns Hopkins and the University of Washington, and in those days, in 1954, no, excuse me, 1957 and 58, you didn't get flown to departments to be interviewed at their expense.
I had visited Johns Hopkins, I never did go down to the Cal, but I was home for the weekend and drove up to Seattle, and the department was small, it had just seven faculty members, but they were really nice, and they represented a nice cross section of the biochemist through that era, and they all had good records of academic achievement.
And it was pretty close to my family, and all living in the state of Washington at the time, and so I figured, why not, and worked out pretty well.
Well, I was pretty on focus when I began graduate school. I, when my fellow students would ask me, what are you interested in?
I'd scratch my head and I'd say, well, I guess I'm interested in enzymes, but I'd like to do some project in enzymes that has potential applications in medicine or biology, what have you.
So, we were required to talk to all the faculty about their research, and the Frank Honeckins was doing work on folate and semology.
So folate is one of the B vitamins, and it's converted to a coenzyme tetrahydrofolate, and tetrahydrofolate is a coenzyme that mobilizes single carbon functional groups.
And so these are involved in methylation, for example, methylation of DNA, methylation of certain amino acids and proteins, and also the methyl group of thymine nucleotides that get into DNA.
And the Honeckins laboratory had just recently shown that, that the action of methotrexate, which is a folate analog, used in cancer treatment,
it was discovered in the 1940s, it was a very potent adylocumic agent that had acted by inhibiting an enzyme called dihydrofolate reductase that reduces folate to tetrahydrofolate.
And I thought this was really interesting, there wasn't very much known about the enzyme at the time, but the fact that the enzyme was a target for a very effective drug, meant that the this whole area of folate,
etymology had the kind of protein enzyme focus that I was interested in with potential applications of significance to medicine.
So I went to work with the phryconicons, and it worked out pretty well for me.
He was one major professor. One of the other reasons that I was interested in his lab was that I learned that he'd had several students who'd managed to finish their PhDs and fairly short order.
And I was interested in getting my PhD and moving on, and that worked out pretty well too, uncompleted by PhD requirements in a little under three and a half years, which is pretty fast by today's standards, where PhD had generally, you know, five-year program or so.
Well, as you, when you were at the University of Washington, where can you do that many?
That's what I got married, that's what you're asking.
Yeah, that's an interesting one too, because if my wife was a graduate school classmate in biochemistry, there were 12 entering students in the class of the entering class of 1958.
And we ended up as lab partners in the lab course, and then later in the year, as teaching assistants, we were assigned together to the, to the reagent room.
It was called the solution room, making up reagents for the biochemistry lab class for dental students.
And we were supposed to put in 10 hours a week of effort in our TA duties, and we worked pretty efficiently together, so I think maybe we worked two or three hours each per week.
And we didn't see each other socially at all at the time, she had a bunch of other boyfriends, and I think we both had the feeling that you didn't get involved with people that you saw every day.
But her interests were more biological, and the genetics department was founded in the spring of 1959, so she transferred to genetics so in our second year, when we were not seeing each other every day, it became a little bit more natural.
And so we got married in the spring of early summer of 1960, and it's kind of interesting because Kate grew up in Berkeley.
Her mother was a research technician in the virus lab, she worked for Wendell Stanley, who won a Nobel Prize for his work in tobacco mosaic virus, and at Berkeley, the virus lab and the biochemistry department were in the same building at the time.
And Kate's mother tended to mother all the graduate students who were unattached.
So if I'd gone to Cal as a graduate student, we've always wondered whether Elsa would have sort of the mother of Megan picked me out of someone suitable for her daughter and would have got us together.
And we had a laugh over that over the years, but you can only live one life at a time.
She also had your first child as a natural candidate.
Right, that wasn't planned. Lawrence was born maybe nine and a half months after we got married and drank champagne from a glass on our first wedding anniversary.
And so Kate never finished her PhD, and she claims, at various times I encourage her to do it.
She worked as a lab technician, and she also worked when I was at Yale. She worked as a teaching assistant in the Department of Biology where I was.
And she always claimed that she really didn't want a PhD anyway. She loves working in the lab, and she's pretty good at it.
But she says she's good at the tactics, but not so good at the strategy at developing a long range line of research and applying for funding and that sort of thing.
So I think she's pretty happy with the kind of careers she had.
Well, somehow it worked.
A lot of my fellow students would go back to work in a lab in the evening, and I just stay home.
And then Kate was very good about after Lawrence was born about seeing that I had a couple of quiet hours every evening.
And I don't remember what's sitting around, but she was still working as a graduate student in the teaching assistant in the genetics department.
Somehow it seemed to work.
So you finished up your PhD in UW and you did a postdoc at Penn.
Yeah, by the time I was approaching finishing my PhD, I knew that I wanted to work in a biological system that had more potential for genetics.
I was getting more involved in the biological side of enzymology than the chemical or biophysical side and reading the literature.
I selected three people whose work I was interested in, and I wanted to be able to go to a lab where the specific experience that I'd had at the graduate student would be useful.
And so Seymour Cohen at the University of Pennsylvania was the one I eventually settled on.
And he was working on bacteriophages, bacterial viruses.
And basically in the late 1940s when he started with his own lab, he'd done what I would call the first biochemical experiments on what happens metabolically during a virus infection cycle using phages model systems for
plant or animal viruses, which of course were much more difficult to work with biochemically at that time.
And in the early 1950s, he and a postdoc had shown that DNA from certain bacteriophages had a very unusual modification in that all of the cytosine residues in DNA were modified by having a hydroxyamethyl group.
And then on the mid to late 1950s, they'd shown the biochemical basis for this that there were new enzymes that were induced after a virus infection that put on the hydroxyamethyl group and that phosphorylated the nucleotides that get us at the point where it could be activated and incorporated in the DNA.
So the whole idea that virus infection stimulated new metabolic pathways was really exciting to me.
And this enzyme to put on the hydroxyamethyl group had a tetrahedral folate co-factor.
So it meant that I could bring some biochemistry to Cohen's lab that would be that would help them out.
And it was nice pairing. But again, in those days, now we're talking 1961, you didn't just hop on a plane to visit every lab that you were going to consider for a postdoc.
So I wrote to three people, and I was going to give a paper at the Federation meeting in April 1961.
This is the Federation of American Societies for Experimental Biology, which at that time included societies for biochemistry, physiology, pharmacology, nutrition and a couple of others.
And it was the big meeting for biochemists to go to.
And so the three people that I was considering would be at the meeting, and I could meet with them there.
This happened very shortly after Lawrence was born. So I really located that a gratitude.
And also my mother and Kate's mother and my grandmother who all came in and helped out.
But I was able to go to the meeting and meet with them. And it was kind of amusing because on the first day of the meeting,
I met Seymour Cohen for the first time. And apparently, my major professor, who had sent a letter of recommendation, sent a two-page letter.
And I didn't learn this till later. But the second page of the letter to Cohen had Dr. Boyer's name at the top of the page.
And so Seymour knew that I was considering more than one laboratory. And he had recently had someone very good who had accepted a postdoc and then went somewhere else and said,
so almost as soon as I shook hands with Seymour and introduced myself, he said, now see here, if I accept you and my laboratory are coming or aren't you.
And so it really set me off. And I wondered who is this guy anyway. But then I met the other two people during that week and by the end of the week.
I decided I wanted to work with Seymour. So I had another appointment with him. And almost before I had a chance to say anything, he said, well I've decided I'd like to have you come and join my lab.
And I said, well, that's funny. I decided I wanted to join your lab too. And then he insisted on driving me to Philadelphia. This is Atlantic City, which is about 60 miles from Philadelphia.
So I could see his lab and meet the other people, which I did. And that was very nice because then I knew them all by the time I joined his group six or eight months later.
So from there, he was on the Yale. How did that fund up and what was it like being trained in faculty member at Yale?
Things were much different back then. I used to get unsolicited offers of assistant professors. They're not supposed to know offers.
I get a letter in the mail from the department chairman that would say would you like to apply for an assistant professorship in our department.
And Seymour Cohen would come into the lab on occasion with letters. They want me to recommend someone for this place of that place, would you like to apply?
Most of the time I said, well, no. But Yale was interesting. My father had worked at the Yale Medical School after the war back in that interval between our lives in Washington State.
And then I knew Yale was a pretty good place. And so I told Seymour, he could go ahead and put my name in, if he'd like. But I told him, I really hope to get back to the West Coast.
And he said, well, fine, I'll write to a couple places where you'd like me to write. And I said, well, UC Davis has the new biochemistry department. It's pretty good. You could write to that.
And also the University of Oregon has this new Institute of Molecular Biology. They have some terrific people there. So he wrote to both places and they both wrote back and said they had positions and they were interested.
I should send my CV and so forth, which I did. And the meantime, then I was invited up to Yale to be interviewed. And it was an interesting day.
I gave the seminar at noon. And then I met immediately after the seminar with the search committee. And they gave me a lunch date, which I was trying to eat at the same time. I was trying to answer the questions. It was pretty stressful.
And one of the search committee members took me to the train at the end of the day. And I went back to Philadelphia. And he said, well, we have to go through a series of steps before we can make.
We can make a decision on anything. But so maybe a while before you hear from us again. And I thought, well, that's fun. I'm not to hurry anyway because I want to see what develops at Davis and Eugene.
But within a week, I had a letter from them saying that the search committee had met and they decided they were going to recommend that I get the appointment and so forth.
And eventually, I did get a formal offer of a letter. And I sort of stalled them as long as I could. And finally, it was a good offer. The salary was pretty poor. My comparison was what my cohort was getting at other places.
But it was the biology department. I didn't consider myself so much a biologist, but they were trying to build up biochemistry and molecular biology within the department. They wanted me to set up a lab class in biochemical research techniques that their graduate students could take.
So that was a challenge. Anyway, I accepted the job on Monday. And then I wrote to the department chairs at Eugene and Davis. And then on Thursday, the phone rang in the lab. And I took the call. It was the department chair at the view of oh, and he said, oh, Dr. Matthews, we just got your letter.
And we're terribly disappointed. We got your last recommendation and the fact we've had a meeting, we decided you'd be ideal for the job we were about to invite you to come out and give a seminar.
Can we get you to change your mind? And I said, I'm sorry, I made a commitment. That was that. And then I went home thinking, I guess I'd give it up my last chance to go to a good university in the Pacific Northwest and who would have known what happened years later.
So I went to Yale in starting in January 1964. And today's assistant professors, of course, get almost the first year without significant teaching responsibilities to set up their lab.
And the very first thing I had to start setting up to teach this lab class that was beginning the end of the, well, the beginning of the spring semester, which was the end of January or the early February. And I had ordered almost everything I needed, but a teaching assistant and I had to set up the lab.
I had to write the protocols for all the labs that the students would do. This is a class of 15 students. So that was very busy with teaching. On the other hand, I also had my NIH research grant that started on January 1st.
Grants were incredibly easy to get back then. And so I was buying equipment and hiring a technician and getting my research labs set up at the same time.
It was sort of a continuation of what I'd done as a postdoc. One of the things, this is actually kind of an amusing story too.
The thesis, my PhD thesis had been on the enzyme dihydrofolate reductase, which I told you was the target enzyme for metatruxate.
And there was another lab that had shown the enzyme that makes the methyl group of thymine reduces a methylene group to the methyl level that requires two electrons.
And the rate of DNA synthesis after T4 phase infection goes up by about tenfold, which means there's a tremendous demand for DNA precursors, including thymine nucleotides.
And so since there's a two-electron reduction, it turns out that the tetrahhydrofolate is oxidized to dihydrofolate.
And so when I became aware of all this, and I was talking to CMR Cohen one day on the lab, and I said, you know with this big increase in demand for thymine nucleotides,
there are all these virus-induced enzymes that you and the other labs have been discovering.
We should be looking for dihydrofolate reductase. There should be a virus-specific form of dihydrofolate reductase as well.
I know how to assay the enzyme. I worked on it for my PhD. So I'd go ahead and do that.
And he said, why don't you focus on the problem that we agreed that you would work on when you came to the lab? And I said, okay.
And then CMR was out of town for three days or so. And I did the experiment. And there was a 24-old increase in the specific activity of dihydrofolate reductase.
And in T-page, in fact, the cells is compared to uninfected cells and turned out to be really easy to show that it was a different enzyme from the corresponding enzyme that existed in the uninfected bacteria.
So one of the things I did, we got a short paper out of it, but one of the things that I did when I went to Yale was just a golden opportunity to get a furry paper.
We just purify the enzyme and characterize it, make mutants that were deficient in the production of the enzyme to see what their phenotype was and so forth.
So there were a number of problems related to DNA precursor metabolism, early in infection by T even.
In fact, there were just that got me off to a pretty decent start. And I published six or eight papers in the first couple of years that was in Yale, even though I had a pretty heavy teaching load.
So you were in Yale for four years, definitely?
Roughly, you got actually three and a half by the calendar, but they started my appointment as assistant professor in July of 1963.
And I was in absentia for the first half year. And then I taught that lab class. And then in the fall, they had me set up a lab for the, what was an undergraduate cell biology course, which was basically biochemistry.
And the fall semester and cell biology and the spring semester. So a colleague and I shared the fall course where he did most of the lecturing I taught the lab.
Did your research in the change of the course that kind of yellow or something specific with that same topic?
Oh, about the research?
Yeah.
I stayed pretty much with that. I was branching out a little bit more biologically and looking at questions such as the regulation, the time-specific regulation of gene expression, virus infection involves a very well scheduled program of events and gene activation and deactivation.
And so I was interested in what turns off the biosynthesis. These are really enzymes that are involved in DNA metabolism. And then the activation of the late proteins, which are mostly structural proteins of the virus and proteins that help the virus assemble.
So I was pretty much sticking with what I knew, but branching out in slightly different directions.
What was your sense of the culture of Yale?
Yeah, that's an interesting question, too. It was all male, of course, as far as the undergraduate student body was concerned.
There was a fair amount of self-satisfaction. The undergraduate students were really bright, at least enough of them were really bright to make it worth the effort to teach them, to make it fun.
The graduate students seemed like kind of a mixed lot to me. I wasn't hugely impressed to them at the time except for some of the very good ones.
And what's turned out in retrospect is that I maybe was a little bit too hard of them because a number of the graduate students that I thought were okay have turned out to have very successful careers. I see their names in the literature all the time.
I guess the students were, they were as good as they thought they were. But in terms of the culture, my decision to leave Yale after a fairly short period there, was hastened.
I knew when I went there, I wouldn't have my whole career there. I didn't really want to live in the East Coast. I knew that most people would take a non-tenger jobs at the Indian Ivy League, move somewhere else.
I thought it was a great place to start from. I might not have left so early, but we had a new department chair who came from Johns Hopkins.
And he was a fairly argumentative sort. He was someone who always wanted to put himself on the, he wanted to polarize discussions.
And so in my last year at Yale, the other biochemists in the department had gone on sabbatical, and no arrangements had been made to take his place.
So I was giving all of his lectures and the cell biology course, as well as teaching the lab in the fall and then teaching the graduate lab in the spring.
And in addition, I'd become a pre-medical advisor. So I had several dozen advisees that I had to meet with and write letters of recommendation for.
And I was being run ragged and trying to keep my research going as well. So there was a social function and I went out to the department chair.
There was a large department, there were about 45 people in the department, so he'd barely knew me.
And I engaged in a conversation and I asked him, what are your thoughts about teaching versus research in an academic environment?
And he said, well, of course you had to be a good teacher if you wanted to succeed at Yale, but the main objective was research.
He said, if you want to say at Yale, your research must assimilate, it must absolutely assimilate.
And if you ever want to be a full professor at Yale in this department, you have to be someone that we can confidently number among the top 50 biologists in the country.
So I went home and I figured with the amount of teaching and committee work I was doing, there wasn't any chance of my rising to the top 50.
And then I also looked around the department and I didn't see very many full professors that I would rank in the top 50 myself, there were one or two.
So that has something to do with the culture, I guess.
So you mentioned in 1967 you moved to Arizona.
Right, that came about because the department chair at Arizona had been one of my professors at the University of Washington, he was on my committee.
He was someone I liked a lot and he called me up one day and told me that the University of Arizona had a new medical school starting and that he just agreed to be chairman of the biochemistry department and what I liked to join him.
And I knew nothing about Arizona at the time.
But I liked his name with on hand a hand and he was in an area of biochemistry that's quite different from mine.
He was an expert on biochemistry fats and lipids and the idea of starting something new.
And there wasn't a matter of being interviewed of search committees and now I've got it basically just offered me a job over the phone.
And then I arranged to go out and visit.
This is in January 1967 and Kate went with me and we had to pay her expenses and it was just a wonderful time.
They put us up in a nice place and we got up in the morning and stepped out the front door and picked a grapefruit for our breakfast off the tree that was going right next to our front door.
And the dean and his wife took us out the dinner one night and in my years at Yale I never met my dean, dean of the faculty of arts and sciences.
And here was the dean taking us out the dinner and telling me how much they hoped that I would decide to go there.
It was a promotion, a rank to be an associate professor, big increase in salary and the opportunity to help shape something because the medical school is brand new.
Everyone in Arizona was excited about the medical school that was starting and it just seemed like the right thing to do.
Yes, I really enjoyed the time that we spent there. We were there for ten and a half years.
And there was a lot of excitement in the first few years having the feeling that we were helping to build a place up.
The medical school there was maybe a half a mile from the main campus, maybe a quarter mile.
It was a five minute bike ride or a ten minute walk.
And there was a little biochemistry group in the chemistry department that was pretty good.
And the art department at the medical school was small.
We had, I think, five or six faculty the whole time I was there.
And so we merged and formed a joint graduate committee in biochemistry.
So that was one of the things that I felt was a contribution on my part and the part of Don Hanahan that we wanted to build bridges.
To the main campus, whereas in other fields like microbiology, there were barriers that were built up.
And the bridges, I think, really were beneficial to the university.
And now they have a combined university wide department that serves the main campus people and the medical school people.
And mostly located on the main campus, I think there are a couple of people left in the medical school building that focused on medical education.
So your obligation to stay in front of the old areas on it?
Yes, they did.
Of course, teaching medical students was quite a different experience.
But I did also teach courses on the main campus and mostly the advanced undergraduate graduate level course.
And some colleagues and I originated some graduate level courses.
I don't think I did any graduate teaching a Yale except for the graduate lab class.
So I taught courses in biological regulatory mechanisms and nucleic acids and so forth, as well as teaching undergraduates and medical students.
But overall, I think the teaching load was a little bit, I hate that term, teaching load, the teaching obligation.
Teaching opportunity was a little bit lighter than what it was at Yale.
And so there's a little bit more time to get involved in research.
And again, there was building the department, recruiting the other faculty members, beginning to recruit graduate students and getting funding for graduate student support and so forth.
It was a different experience.
So what kind of, what was your line of research?
Well, I continued with some of the projects that were underway when I left Yale and picked up some new ones.
But they, for the most part, they had to do with the enzymology and regulation of DNA precursors.
One thing that happened was that people involved in T4 bacteriophage genetics had generated a large number of mutants that were available and there were mutants in maybe 15 genes that were involved in DNA synthesis.
And it wasn't clear what the biochemical functions of all these genes coded for.
And so I got involved in that a little bit to what extent do we, might some of these genes have to do with DNA precursors and metabolism, to what extent might they have to do with DNA replication itself.
And so at some stage, I became interested in the relationship between the synthesis of the four DNA precursors, A, G, C, and T to make it simplest.
And the replication apparatus, because DNA replication is a very rapid process.
And in bacteria or in phase infected bacteria, the DNA chain will grow at something like 7 or 800 dupletides per second.
So I started thinking, how can the enzymes that are making the precursors throughout the cell, how can a channel precursors to DNA polymerase, the replication apparatus, fast enough to sustain this rate.
So I started working on the premise that there was a super molecular organization within the infected cell with the precursor enzymes physically located close to the replica on the machinery that synthesized the DNA so that you could get channeling of precursors to DNA replication sites.
And that was a pretty big part of my research. For several of the years I was there, I wanted to require quite a bit of time that I was here, but we picked up some lines of research on comparable questions in mammalian cells, working in tissue culture.
I also had a couple of students who worked on theses quite independently on things that were quite different from anything that I did. One of them was sure that aging was a question of gene expression and that you should be able to learn something about aging if you do something about the kinetics of dupletic acid metabolism.
And he did a thesis that was partly computational, partly biochemical on RNA metabolism that he published one paper published independently and one paper he put my name on as a curious gesture.
And after I came here, he joined my lab again. He had a grant and he needed a site that he could work for, he could work fairly independently and he remembered what him have his own head.
So he was here for a couple of years and then he got the idea of antisense as a potential drug and founded a company called antivirals in his recreation room here in Corvallis.
And then that turned into ultimately into avi by a farmer, which is about a technology company in Corvallis.
And eventually he left them and formed another company, gene tools, which is in phalloma and it's hugely successful.
So even though all I provided was a supporting environment at Arizona, it's turned out having a very nice spin-off here.
We're at about an hour, are you going to know, okay?
Yeah, come on.
So this is your first experience of the Southwest, and you mentioned the experience of taking it great through the Southwest.
We really enjoyed living there and both Kate and I are pretty enthusiastic outdoors people.
And we found out that there's a lot more variety in Arizona than we ever believed there was.
Tucson is bring by four mountain ranges and we did a lot of backpacking there and we went camping in Mexico.
It turned out there were some very nice beach areas on the Gulf of California that we went and did weekend camping at.
And so we really did everything we could to enjoy and profit from the Southwest.
And we miss a lot of that. We miss being able to get into the out of doors 12 months of the year very easily.
But Tucson was growing with very little planning and Tucson is one of the largest cities in the world that gets all of its water from underground.
And when the chance came to come here, of course it was professionally a very nice opportunity.
We were happy to.
So I wondered, do we really want to move?
But one of the features was, how much longer is it going to mean up water to sustain the population?
How much longer are we going to have these beautiful desert environments that real estate the developments are crowding on to?
So that all convinced us that we really enjoyed the 10 years there but maybe it was time to go.
And every time we go back to Tucson, we're horrified at the additional growth that's occurred.
Do you put the sabbatical of the US, UCSD in 1973?
Right. Kate still criticizes me on occasion for not having taken a European sabbatical then because our children were something like 12 and 14 of them.
And they probably really would have profited from a year in Europe.
But I still had a fairly small research group and wanted to stay in reasonable close touch with them.
And of course, UCSD was a growing academic environment with some superb people and we lived near the beach.
So it was a very nice living for the year.
I split the year between two different laboratories.
So I had two different kinds of experiences.
And it was very nice. It was a good sabbatical.
What did you do there?
The first six months I worked with a guy named Gordon Sado who was an expert on culturing cells and maintaining their differentiated characteristics in culture.
And I wanted to learn literature culture because I wanted to be able to branch out with our interests into mammalian systems so I could take what we were learning in microbial model systems and apply them to mammalian or maybe human systems so I wanted to learn literature culture.
So I did a project that had to do with growth factors in cell culture.
And then in the second six months, I went to the script's institutional oceanography where I had a very good friend who was an expert on the biochemistry of early events in fertilization using the sea urchin.
And so fertilization is a little comparable to the phaging effect that is among the metabolic changes that occurs as a huge turn on a DNA synthesis.
And the cleavage cycles, the cell cleavage cycles are very fast. So DNA genomes are reproduced in the order of half an hour or so.
And so the question in my mind was, where do the precursors come from? Are they stored or is there a turn out synthesis? So that was what I worked on in Dave's lab.
And it turned out that the sea urchin egg has huge supplies of deoxyneucleuside triphosphates and then backup pools of the monophosphates and the triphosphates.
So the egg is really geared to activate DNA synthesis very soon after fertilization.
And I thought about going back and working on that system a little bit on my own after I came here, but never got around to it.
There are plenty of other things to do.
That's right. That's great.
No, I don't think so.
Yeah, he was been at the Sock Institute. I've forgotten when he moved there. I should know that because I reviewed the biography of France as quick just a few months ago for a journal and made fascinating reading.
It was always like, yeah, in my review, I wrote that I've been asked to review quite a few scientific books over the years.
This is the first one I actually read word for word cover for cover cover. It's just read like a novel.
But I'm pretty sure that was before Kirk had moved to Sock.
Over here.
What was that right?
Which I don't know about that because I knew the name already. I knew he was a famous historian of science, the recent historian of science.
Yeah.
Seymour Cohen was very interested in the early history of molecular biology.
He was pretty unpopular with the with the crowd in that field because he was so aggressively pro biochemical and didn't necessarily believe in genetics.
And Seymour Cohen was the first grad with student of Irwin Shargaf.
Shargaf who had promulgated the base composition of regularities that helped Watson quick developed their model.
And Shargaf had been very bitter about being left out of credit for that.
And I think Seymour shared Shargaf's bitterness to some extent.
And so when the Nobel Prize was announced, I was in Seymour's lab. And this is 1962.
And it went to Watson and Kirk and Maurice Wilkins.
And so Seymour came into the lab and said, well, if they were going to
include Wilkins and the Nobel Prize, they should have included Shargaf because his contribution was just as substantial.
And I think he could make a pretty good case for that. But of course, the Nobel Prize is limited to three awardees.
So I'm sure that didn't do very much for Irwin Shargaf's mood either.
But he was the average age for the talented full guy.
Yeah, he was. In fact, Shargaf was the one who got me started thinking about Seymour Cohen.
Because my second year in graduate school, Shargaf came to Seattle and gave a series of lectures.
And during the lectures, he talked about virus and dosenzyme.
He talked about work by, done by, quote, my student, Seymour Cohen, unquote.
And so immediately went to the literature and started reading Seymour Cohen's papers.
I'd never heard them before. And that was what got me fired up.
And the fact that Seymour was Irwin Shargaf's student.
At some point, I met the guy that was the chairman of biochemistry at Columbia when Shargaf had moved from Europe.
I think he was a refugee. And the Columbia took him in.
And so the chairman, his name was Hans Clarke. He was quite a distinguished biochemist.
Tell me what you're doing, Dr. Matthew. And I said, well, I'm a postdoc in the University of Pennsylvania.
Oh, who are you working with? I'm working with Seymour Cohen.
Oh, yes. Seymour. He's one of my boys, you know.
It was very paternal or paternalistic.
And so Seymour was Irwin Shargaf's student.
But it turned out that when Seymour was working on his postdoc or on his PhD,
neither of them was working on nucleic acids at the time.
Seymour had done his PhD thesis on lung surfactant, which is a phospholipid.
And it wasn't until years later that both Shargaf and Cohen independently started working on nucleic acid biochemistry.
So there's something kind of fascinating about the personalities involved in the recent history of science.
Yeah. Cohen felt like he was definitely a pretty big figure in life.
He was, you know. He taught a famous course in comparative biochemistry.
I don't remember why I never sat in on the course I should have.
But he was very broadly based. He was very rigorous in his thinking.
And he had a pretty priculous personality.
So he was definitely a challenge to work for.
But he was so broad.
And he had so many ideas that I think it influenced me to read pretty widely in science and trying to maintain a broad awareness.
That's helping a lot and writing a textbook.
And also, since I became a member of the editorial board of the Journal of Biological Chemistry,
I get sent papers to review that are way, way outside of my area because the editors know that I can sit down and read something.
I got a paper to review a couple of years ago on the biochemistry body order, if you believe that.
Well, we converted this a little bit in 1972.
Oh, I see what it sounds like. They made a pretty good offer to you.
Right. There was an interesting situation too.
I didn't have any real reason to believe ours on it.
I said, you can always find things to feel uneasy about.
But I felt pretty well accepted on the campus.
But I said my family was all still in the Pacific Northwest.
And so I kept my eye out for opportunities.
And the OSU advertised for a chair of the Department of Biochemistry and Biophysics and Science.
So I wrote, sent my CV, and eventually was asked for my references,
always sent the names, references, and eventually was asked to interview.
And I had enough information about the department to know that it was a pretty good department.
And they sent me the data on the research funding of the faculty.
And there were 14 faculty at the time.
And everyone except one had some kind of outside research funding.
Publication records looked pretty good.
So on the days when I was interviewed, it was a two day or two and a half day process.
I had a series of half hour talks with the faculty.
And each one, I would say, you know, you got a good department.
Why are you looking outside for your chair?
You could fill the chairmanship inside.
And I got told pretty much the same thing by everyone.
And of course, when you get consistency, that's a pretty good sign.
And what they said was, this is our only chance to bring in a senior level faculty person
to bring in a funded research program and give a jump start to our department's reputation.
Because if we appointed an inside person, the chair of them would have to fill the vacancy at the system professor level.
So that made sense.
And they said that the department was in pretty good shape, scientifically.
And personally, everyone got along, which really seemed to be the case.
And so what they wanted was someone who was a pretty active scientist and teacher who was willing to do some administration and leadership.
And that was sort of how I saw myself.
I knew by that time I could probably handle the administrative details of being a department chair,
but it wasn't the be all and end all of my existence.
And so it was a pretty good fit.
And then after a few weeks after the interview with the dean called up to offer me a job, it was my 40th birthday.
And so it seemed like a, it seemed like an omen of some kind.
And that was kind of amusing too, because I put in a call, oh, this happened later on.
So I got the offer and then Kate and I were invited back to visit again in this time.
It was a recruitment visit, and it was very pleasant again.
And then went back home and after a while thought things over and decided I would accept the job.
So I put in a call to the dean and he was out of the office.
And he would call back and I sat there thinking I was about to make a decision that would affect the rest of my life.
And the phone rang, and I thought it was Dean Prouse calling me back.
No, it was the guy from the biochemistry department of the University of California, Davis,
asking if I'd like to be considered for the chairmanship of the department there.
And I said, you got a great department, but I think it's a little too late.
So what was the set of priorities for the chairmanship in the OSU?
The main priority for me was for me to keep my research program visible and productive.
It's quite a job to move a research program.
I knew that the department would be in pretty good shape.
There were a few things that needed to be done.
You know, I knew I could handle whatever teaching I need to do here.
But not all the people that were working with me and Tucson chose to come.
So I had to appoint some more people.
And my major research grant had, I don't remember a year and a half or so to run.
And I just wanted to make sure that I'd got enough papers out during that time.
So I'd be competitive.
It was grants were already that's now in the late 1970s.
The grant situation was beginning to tighten up.
So that was my first priority.
It worked out pretty well.
Did the administrative pressures change over time?
Yes.
But actually getting back to priorities for just a minute,
there were some things in the department early on that I felt should get taken care of.
One was the fact that graduate students,
there was hardly any money in the department to support teaching assistance.
So there wasn't much state money that would support students who weren't committed to allow.
So almost all the students came on research assistantships,
which meant they were committed to the lab whose research grant was paying their assistantship.
And I thought that a first year graduate program should have
opportunity for students to come on committed.
I thought it was a great strength that students could come here and start right to work with a person
that they wanted to work with but that many students come without a specific set of interest
and they should have an opportunity to go through rotations.
So pretty high priority for me early on was to get an NIH training grant that would provide funds for
tuition and stipends for half a dozen students or so so that we could bring out a few
and give them a year to look around and then go on to research assistantships.
And my first attempt was unsuccessful.
That was kind of interesting too because we got kind of a mediocre score on the grant application
and really kind of a snotty critique in which the whoever reviewed the grant said the training record
of the faculty doesn't seem to be particularly strong.
Most of the graduate seemed to have taken jobs in industry.
And I wrote to the NIH and I said, what is this?
It seems to me that Congress which funds the NIH might have second thoughts about the training
and program of industrial positions are seeing a second rate.
So I'm going to revise the application and I'd like to have a site visit so you can see what we have out here.
And so the second time we had a site visit and we got the grant and had it for two or three cycles.
So that was sort of an institutional priority for me.
And then in 1981, so this was an opportunity that sort of dumped in my lap but it was an institutional priority for me.
The dean called me in and said that the MJ Murdoch Charitable Trust, you know about the Murdoch Trust.
This is a large foundation that was created from the estate of Jack Murdoch who was one of the founders of Tectronics.
Murdoch died prematurely in an airplane accident.
And he left most of the state entrusted as a foundation to support educational, charitable, and community organizations of Southern Northwest.
And they used to give project grants to faculty here.
But apparently the trust had told President Winkert that they now wanted to focus their grants more on large multi-person projects that represented institutional priorities.
And so the dean and the president and others then decided that he was time to make a push in molecular biology.
And so they called me in as the person to sort of the point person to write something up.
And it was clear, that was right.
It was very much a time to make a push even though that doesn't pretty good people scattered around the university here in that area.
And it was clear to me that there's multi-departmental cooperation is very strong on this campus.
And so whatever we did should be in a multi-departmental, multi-disciplinary framework.
So I proposed that the university create something that would be called the Center for Gene Research.
And that the grant then fund three positions and pay their salaries and start-up costs for two years with the commitment by the university that their salaries would be continued at the end of that two years.
And that search would be conducted in a multi-departmental framework.
There was a little money also for project grants for the faculty that was here.
And so then when the grant was funded, we had a multi-departmental search that bought three excellent people in.
One who came to our department is now the chairman of our department, Gary Merrill.
One who went to botany, Carol Rubin, and one who went to microbiology.
And that's Dennis Ruby who's now the chief scientific officer at Seagal Farm of Seagal.
So very good people.
In the meantime, the people in the ag school wanted to form a biotechnology institute or biotechnology center.
And President Wicker told him that the campus wasn't big enough to have two competing centers and areas related to biotechnology.
And they'd better work with us.
So we made the center.
I mean, I had no idea it would grow to something that encompassed the whole campus the way it did, but it turned out to be very successful.
And in the first several years, I think 1985, the center had caught on so well that the legislature appropriated a pretty fierce chunk of change as continuing a continuing budget for that time with the CGRB.
So that was something else that worked out pretty well.
And then I served the director of the center for a year and a half or so after the first director left the fairly abruptly.
But what did the center stand for?
Well, it continued to get bigger and stronger.
And after I resigned as director because I couldn't handle two administrative jobs and still keep a research lab going and keep my teaching going.
And so there was sort of an interim appointment made while there was an outside search and Russ mines came from the University of Nebraska and he built it up a bit.
And then he retired and then the really big push came when Jim Carrington was brought in.
And of course he had a superb research program.
And so I think his program attracted a lot of other people and departments all over the campus were beginning to use molecular biology techniques.
So the center and then Jim changed the focus to the center with a big emphasis on genomics and computational biology.
In fact, the name of the center was changed. I didn't realize this for a couple of years. It's still the CGRB.
But now instead of being the center for gene research and biotechnology, it's the center for genomics research and bio computing.
And so five or six years ago, there was a university wide hiring initiative in genomics and bio computing.
And there was another multi departmental search that I think brought five faculty members.
And they're outstanding people. One of them is Michael Freitag who came to the art department and his office is right next door to mine.
And one is Todd Mochler and botanates and extremely well.
I think he I think he left Carrington left this year to become president of the director of the Danforth foundation in St. Louis.
I just learned it there to the Mochler one with him. But it's really outstanding. People came and the focus to the center change. And it's it's well rooted in the university, the central service lab, which which the center maintains carries out multi investigator procedures, nucleic acid sequencing and oligopeptide synthesis.
That it's been doing for years, but it also has a very large computational and second generation DNA sequencing capability grafted on. So it's got bigger and stronger over the years.
So getting back to the administrative responsibilities, how did they shift over the years?
They shifted in that it got it got harder and harder to get money and there was a little bit more administration that had to get done.
So the first year or two I was here, one of my colleagues got money and one of his grants, $100,000 to buy an electron microscope.
This is one our department was telling what are your all. And he came to me said we need a room to put the electron microscope in it. I said, well, I guess we're going to have to see the deans. We want to see Dean Kraus.
And it was maybe a 15 minute conversation. And he found 50 some thousand dollars to renovate some space on the first floor to wonder. And so we got the pretty substantial amount of money on the basis of a short one short conversation.
And getting money became harder and harder and at one point. So our department was very has always been very heavily involved with the Environmental Health Science Center.
This is a center that's funded with a core grant from the National Institute of Environmental Health Sciences.
It was originally headquartered basically on what used to be the Department of Agricultural Chemistry. And that again is a center that's become bigger and stronger over the years.
And at some point when the previous director retired, Don Reed, who was an art department, became the director so we're heavily involved with that center.
And one of the hardest things for me in my last several years of being department share was accumulating competitive startup packages when we wanted to recruit a faculty member.
That's one thing to get a salary line. But around the country the amount of money you had to put together to track someone who was getting larger and larger because a new assistant professor couldn't count on getting his or her first grant funded and needed some money from day one.
And I remember one of the people who came in as vice president for research, which is of course one of the major sources that we would go to, I think I've suppressed his name because I dislike him so much.
Somehow or another, he never caught on to the idea that the discretionary funds he had as a disposal, one of the highest priorities of them should be contributions toward setup funds.
And Don Reed was still the director of the EHSC and I talked or so blue in the face before we got a token contribution from them and we were just really irritated.
And I remember another interesting episode we had with the Environmental Health Science Center. When Don Reed became director of the center, this was in the early 1980s, he also was pretty expansionist, he wanted to build and solidify the EHSC and this sort of parenthetical.
In my opinion, one of the strengths of Oregon State, I said something about the inter-departmental cooperation, you have strong individual departments but you have these centers that span departmental boundaries, we have the CGRB, the EHSC and of course the Linus Pauling Institute.
And I think all of these centers have done nothing but good things for the university by bringing in more research strength.
So one thing that Don Reed wanted to do was to use the funds he had in the center to establish two or three new faculty positions that would be partly funded by the EHSC and partly funded by university funds.
So one of the positions would be in our department, if you wanted to get someone who was using cell culture to study basically areas related to environmental toxicology.
And the Dean at the time said well, our department was over staffed already that we had too many faculty positions for the number of credit hours that we taught, you know, the kind of thinking that administrators go through.
And of course, both Don and I saw this as a great opportunity to strengthen the department research wise and bring in some more money to the department.
And Don was pretty aggressive, so he set up a appointment meeting with President Baker and six or eight of a sat around the table, including Don and myself and George Keller who was the vice president for research at the time.
And Dean Sugahara, Dean of the College of Science and the president, maybe one or two others.
And Dean Sugahara went through his routine that the department was over staffed already and he couldn't justify putting even a part of his salary into our budget under the circumstances.
And then Don Reed gave his pitch, I don't think I said much of anything.
I was there to support Don got all the negative brownie points from the Dean.
And at the end of Don's talk, President Baker said, well, it sounds like a pretty good proposal.
Let's go ahead with it. And I thought the Dean was going to cry.
And so from that point on, Don Reed's name was poison in the College of Science.
But it worked out very well. He brought in David Barnes, who's no longer here, but that position was established.
And we have got a research facility that's helped the whole campus community.
And then he brought in Dale Mosbow in what was at camp.
And Mosbow had a superb research program until he died very young in 2004.
But the idea that you could use Center funds to strengthen research programs within departments,
and the strength and inter-departmental cooperation has been a key note for the CDRB, the EHSC, and the Linus Paulingist.
In fact, the really history of the Linus Paulingist is pretty interesting, too.
Don Reed was acting director of the Institute. Well, we had a search for director.
And I was chair of the search committee that brought both right here.
And that worked out extremely successfully. Both it's so good.
And the people he brought in are just outstanding.
But I think the only time I ever had a one-on-one conversation with President Brisser was shortly.
While this was all underway, I think I don't remember whether Balls Friday arrived yet, or when we were still having research.
But of course it was concerned all over the campus about LPI, how it would drain research resources away from the administration.
And of course the Linus Pauling Institute in California was pretty mixed with scientific quality.
And that was a bit of a concern. But John Byrne really pushed the whole thing.
It was his legacy to the university. And so Brisser and I were walking together from some function.
And it was just the two of us. And he said, what do you think about this move of the Linus Pauling Institute anyway?
It was obvious. He was pretty negative about the whole thing.
And I said it doesn't make any difference what you or I think about it. It's happening anyway.
At the time I think I was one of the cautious ones out of two.
But I would become nothing but a supporter because we were so fortunate in getting Balls to come here as our first choice.
I thought the recruitment would be very difficult because the LPI occupied space that our department had occupied before we moved to Ag and Life Sciences.
And the space was pretty trashed. But Balls saw that it could work.
They did a little bit of renovation. And of course they said that a new building would be something that would be fairly high on the priority scale.
But it took a long time. But it worked.
So you asked about the administrative load. The other thing that happened in those last several years was the planning of the Ag and Life Sciences building.
That took a lot of time. And in the initial planning I became aware that there were documents in the university that had five levels of space assignment depending on what kind of department or college you were in.
And of course agricultural forestry were on the highest level.
Number square feet per FTE of lab space, square feet per FTE for office space.
And science was a level below Ag.
And so we started having our first planning meetings.
And it was mostly Ag people, of course, because of the Ag and Life Sciences.
And biochemistry biophysics was put into the department sort of accidentally. And the way I understood it was the administration was having trouble assembling funding for the building.
And it's all seriously, but the way I heard it was the George Keller said, well, we don't have enough pizzazz in the building.
We have range science. We have ag administration. We have horticulture. They're all perfectly justifiable.
But we need to put some of our environmental science. We need to put some of our biotechnology in there.
And apparently Dean Horn was at the planning meeting. He said, well, biochemistry biophysics is heavily involved in both biotechnology and environmental health science.
So we were moved in very quickly. But then it turned out that they wanted to assign us space on the science level assignment.
And I figured if we're moving to the new building, we need to have the same kind of space allocation that the other departments in the building had.
Is about that time about that time a friend of mine who was chairman of the search committee for Dean of Science at Penn State invited me to come to look at the job.
And after I looked at it, it was, I didn't want the job, but it was clear that they wanted me.
So I went to talk to Graham Spaniard, of course, who would come here from Penn State, and now his back there is one of the most successful university presidents in the country.
And Graham was, was very excited to hear that they wanted me to go to Penn State. He didn't talk to me at all about what can we do to keep you.
He wanted to know a lot about what was happening at Penn State and so forth.
But he did eventually, you know, what would it take to keep you? And I had two things in mind that would benefit the department.
And one of them was space allocation of the new building. I said they're basically trying us to talk and sound on space.
We have adequate space in one of the spaces kind of second rate quality was, but if we're going to be asked to help plan a new building and move into space, we need to, we need to be assured that we don't have to accept any less square footage of what we have now.
So he put that on a letter and that helped me a lot is went through the planning process, but that took a lot of time too.
Were there any major shifts in your research during the years?
Yes, not major. I've always, I've always been involved in, in nucleotide, the oxygen nucleotide and DNA precursor in zymology and biochemistry.
Yeah, I can tell you look, yeah, the answer is yes, I'll get to that in a minute.
But I'll tell you another story about the new building that you might find entertaining.
This has to do with the administrative load and you have to watch these guys all the time, actually two stories.
One time we were in a meeting in the administration building and they, we were being told that there wasn't enough money to build a building with size that was being discussed at the beginning.
And we were going all around the table, what can we do about this cut back and that cut back?
And it was, it was getting pretty late in the country in the evening, you know, six o'clock, six, three or so.
And the guy named Ed Cote was the vice president for the administration of the time and he was kind of a laughing stock in the faculty.
And he was getting more and more impatient.
He basically said, finally, hey, it's getting late here.
Let's just lop off a floor and we can leave.
So that's a solidified review about Ed Cote.
And somehow it ended up that the building was built.
I think the university got a bargain. It's a very good building.
He was done with the funds available.
But at one point the architect told me.
That we've built a prototype laboratory.
So you and your colleagues can go over, look at it, look at the cabinets, look at the shell, look at the bench top, look at the utility and see what it looked like.
And I said, well, it's in, in Moreland Hall, there's a member of the psychology faculty.
Bill Smotheren, who does physiological work.
And he needed an upgrade to his lab.
So we've built that as a prototype lab and you can go on and see what it looks like.
And so we went over and it did its nice lab.
And so we could see what kind of countertops they were going to have and the new building and so forth.
And then it occurred to me to ask someone, hey, where the money come from to do this?
And it turns out that Bill Smotheren had been offered a job in another institution.
And he needed, in order to stay, one of the things that he needed was an upgrade to his lab.
So we went to his dean, the dean went to the then provost.
And somehow things had come about so that the money was siphoned out of our building project to build this guy's lab.
And so we raised hell about it.
And so they had to find the money from somewhere else and put it back into the building project.
So you had to be on your toes all the time about these guys.
So getting back to research.
I had a graduate student in the early who finished in about 1982.
Who did his thesis on the DNA precursor supply for the mitochondrial genome?
I'd seen a paper in the literature that suggested that the mitochondrial genome is fed by a distinct precursor pool that might be generated within the mitochondria.
And so Rick Besswick did a thesis on the series of experiments and indicated, yes, indeed, that the pools were physically distinct and the regulatory sense as well.
And then that sort of sat there until the late 1990s.
And another graduate student joined our group, Shi Wei Song, Chinese student, who wanted to follow up on that work.
He was a medical degree from China.
And the number of diseases had been described that have genetic effects within the mitochondria.
And some of them are mutations within the mitochondrial genome.
Some of them are mutations within the nuclear genome that encode proteins that are transported into mitochondria and function there.
And so there's some very interesting diseases.
And of course now there's also the idea that accumulation of mutations in the mitochondrial genome is partly responsible both cancer and aging.
Since we knew that aspects of DNA precursor metabolism are mutagenic determinants.
That is metabolic derangement.
But if you will, the oxygenucleotide metabolism can affect the mutation rate.
We wanted to learn more about the mitochondrial pools of DNA precursors where they came from, how they were regulated, and how this might affect the mutation rate.
It turns out the mutation rate for the mitochondrial genome is much higher than it is for the nuclear genome.
And why should this be?
So Shi Wei did his thesis on this, and he was one of my last graduate students to finish.
But by the time he started publishing papers from his thesis, we began to get some notice for this.
So I got funding actually after I retired and was hoping I'd be able to keep research funding going because this was turning out to be a pretty productive line of research.
So in fact, that has been the total of our research since about 2003 and had pretty decent funding for that.
During that time, the three graduate students that I had at the time I retired in 2002, they took two or three or four years to finish and they were done.
But after that, I kept my lab going with a technician and a postdoc and one or two undergrad was supposed to be done.
Now I've decided to let my funding expire and there's a new faculty member in our department that's going to take over our lab.
So my last grant expires the end of the year.
But for the last few years, it's taken the knowledge and the background I have.
And the oxygen nucleotide metabolism just applied it to mammalian cells and mitochondrial metabolism.
The last sort of big topic I'd like to talk about is your textbook by chemistry.
So what was the process in which you had been told that you were going to do this?
In 1983 and 1984, there were two major texts that came out.
And we have two sort of advanced level undergraduate courses.
BB-450, 451, which most students take as a two quarter sequence.
And then BB-494-91 and 492.
And these can both be taken under graduate or graduate.
And these two books came out and one of them we assigned to the 450 course and one we adopted for the 490 course.
And they're both terrible.
And at some point in the spring, I was eating my lunch in my office and a publisher's representative came in.
And I sort of set my sandwich aside.
And so I told them how disappointed we were with all the textbooks that were on the market.
And he said, well, you know so much about what's wrong with all these books.
You ought to be writing your own book.
And I said, are you crazy?
I don't have the time or the expertise to write a whole book.
I said, well, get a co-author.
Well, I was about to go on sabbatical leave to Sweden and I thought, well, you know, maybe I could write in the evening working a lot during the day.
So it's not a completely crazy idea.
And I was talking to my colleague, Bob Becker, about this.
And he said, well, why don't you talk to Ken Van Holt?
He's talked about writing textbooks from time to time.
And Ken and I had taught graduate level courses together.
I knew he was extremely articulate, brilliant scientist, and he had a good sense of humor.
And also was much more of a physical biochemist than I am.
His PhD is actually in physical chemistry.
So I went and talked to Ken.
And he said, well, I'd have to be crazy to even think about something like this.
But yes, I am interested.
So we went down and visited the publisher and talked to our editor, the woman who would be our editor.
And she said that each of us should write a sample chapter, and we should write a chapter outline and a perspective sample chapter.
And she bought each of us a compact computer.
This is just before Macintosh came out, but there were slightly portable computers.
So I took one with me to Stockholm.
And by the time I'd finished writing my sample chapter, I thought this is more work than I want to let myself in for.
But we sent the material in.
And in December, Diane called up.
She said the reviewers are like what we've written.
And they thought we ought to go ahead.
So they wanted to sign us for contract.
So I thought, oh, God, what do I do now?
And I called Ken.
And he said, oh, yeah, I said, I think it's terrific.
Let's go.
There was no alternative.
And we went ahead with it.
And many times during the writing process, I thought I was crazy to get involved in this.
If I could quit, I would.
But in retrospect, I'm glad that we stuck with it.
And it took a long time because it was 1984 that they first started talking to us about the book.
It was really 85 when we signed the contract.
And then I had a lot of things that got me behind schedule when I came back from sabbatical.
And we didn't really plan to end the work on an any kind of scheduled basis till spring or so of 1986.
But we had the first draft done maybe in spring of 88.
No, it must have been 80.
I don't remember the dates now because it took a year or so to produce the book after the chapter drafts were done.
So the whole thing was about almost a five year process.
And the subsequent additions were much easier.
Was it a difficult process to establish the point of view of the two authors that you're going to be writing the book?
Actually, that was the easiest part.
Ken and I split up responsibility for chapters.
Very easily we agreed to read each other's chapters.
I did most of the metabolism.
He did most of the structural biochemistry.
And we sort of split the molecular biology, the genetic biochemistry.
And the editors were very concerned about merging our prose styles.
I think we did pretty well.
Although now that I'm writing some for our fourth edition, which he's not involved in,
I'm writing some rewriting some chapters he wrote.
And I'm seeing some differences between his writing style and mine.
But the difficulty we had in the first edition was some pretty spirited arguments with our editors.
They kept a pretty heavy hand on us.
And we disagreed with them pretty frequently.
But they ended up being pretty good friends.
And we had a different editorial team each of the editions.
But that was where the energy came out.
But Ken and I had nothing but a good relationship.
The one thing that was disappointing was that he spends almost half the year at his summer home in Woods Hole.
That he established when he was at the University of Illinois before he came here and that's chooses.
So it wasn't always a matter of just walking down the hall if I wanted to talk to him.
But he worked out pretty well.
It did pretty well.
I can't tell you how much the percentage of the market had captured.
But the publisher was very pleased.
In terms of the royalties, we were very pleased.
And I've been told by quite a few people.
I mean, this is not something I should be talking about, but I've been told that it's the most clearly written book on the market.
And I know it brought us a lot of attention.
I know when I was in sabbatical leave in Sweden, I got a call one day.
And from someone at the University of Uppsala, they wanted me to come and meet with a group of their biochemistry teachers to tell them my thoughts about teaching biochemistry.
I gave a talk in South Africa a few years ago.
And that their biochemistry meeting and the students were coming up and wanting to be photographed with me because they had used our book.
So a lot of things happened that were very gratifying to the ego.
So from that standpoint, I guess our book was received well enough that it was worth the effort and worth the effort after the project.
I thought was dead after the third edition was done, that it was worth picking up for the fourth edition.
As you look back on your career, what are some of the things that your public says?
I guess the first thing is the fact that I trained 35 PhD students and most of them have done very well on their careers.
And that's like being a parent and most of them stated enough contact that I had the feeling that I made a difference in their lives.
Another thing that I've been satisfied with is maintaining a balance of teaching and research through all the positions I've had because I always enjoyed teaching.
I'm pretty enthusiastic about the field.
I like to know what's going on in the field. I like to explain to others whether it's in writing or speaking.
And I like to set an example for colleagues who might be focused only on their research that you can be a successful research scientist and still maintain personal communication with students with colleagues.
With people in other departments on the campus that science can be a social activity.
So I would say the breadth of interest and association that has something else I take satisfaction in.
And being able to say funded for years in a very difficult, increasingly difficult environment.
And the book, I mean that's a pretty big part of my life, put a pretty big strain in our family situation for a long time but now Kate is just as supportive about the whole thing as I am.
She likes it when I come home and tell her stories about the experience that we had.
So it's been a big plus also.
Is there anything that we miss that we should pass on?
Well, yeah, I guess there's always been the thought about what, again, parallel lies parallel universes.
What if I go on into medicine?
And that's hit it several times when I was in college trying to decide which way to go.
Of course, my father was a doctor. I thought the world of him.
And I talked and I catered and maybe we could go out of practice together.
And that could have been fun.
But dad was very good about not putting pressure on.
He said it was my decision whether to go on the science or medicine.
And you asked about the Reed College culture earlier.
And premeds were sort of frowned on as being grade lovers.
Even though Reed gave grades, but the students weren't told what the grades were.
And the idea was to make you less grade causes.
But the premeds were a little more narrow and they were interested.
And I saw there was something about the culture that the highest level of acceptance was the people that wanted to go on into university and college professors.
So that helped.
And then I was pointed in that direction.
But when I went to Arizona and started teaching medical students,
I realized that biochemistry in that context is a lot different.
And my father never actually conveyed to me the intellectual stimulation of medicine as a multi-departmental scientific activity.
It was partly that he was in practice.
He was an internist, but a lot of his patients did have routine troubles that didn't give him much stimulation.
So he didn't convey that part of it.
But once I had to learn to teach biochemistry in a way that medical students would accept.
And once I started interacting with him, the college I realized that medicine is a lot different from what I thought it was.
And so at some point after I'd been there a few years, early seventies,
I read that the University of Miami had created a fast track MD program for PhDs in the biomedical sciences.
You could finish a MD degree in a year and a half to two years.
I was pretty interested in this.
So I applied for it.
It was accepted.
And then I went to talk to the department chairman.
The idea being that one of the years I could get partial support by being on sabbatical leave.
And then we'd use our own resources for the rest.
And when I told him about it, he looks though he'd been kicked in the stomach.
And then he talked to my colleagues, which I always felt was improper.
I thought that my conversation was just one on one.
But after a week, he said that the department had decided they really didn't want me to do this.
Well, obviously I could have done it anyway, but I would have had to resign.
I could have resigned.
You know, I thought it over.
And by that time our children were date and 10.
We were pretty well settled and two son.
And there wasn't any, and I enjoyed what I was doing.
There wasn't any real, there wasn't any reason that I had to do this.
But I've always wondered what it would have been like if I had a current medicine.
Would I have gone into medical research?
Or would I have been a primary in practice?
Would I have gotten the intellectual stimulation?
Would I have enjoyed the kind of breadth of awareness of what's happening?
Cutting edge science and all the rest of it.
It'd be nice if you could live too long.
But that's something I just have to live with, I guess.
So obviously we're also very proud of our two children, Lawrence, who was, as I said, born very shortly after our marriage.
And then Anne was born a couple of years later.
Lawrence ended up going to the University of Washington for a PhD in biochemistry.
He was in the same department I was.
And the department had changed a lot since then.
He's now out of science, but he got a great start to his career.
He did a postdoc in Sweden, and then a second postdoc in the Sock Institute.
And he did a piece of work that made him quite well known.
He had four excellent faculty offers, and he was an assistant professor at the University of Michigan for several years.
And he had an epiphany, and now he's a teacher in the Waldorf school system.
And we'll go into detail about that.
But he is much happier doing that than he ever was as a university faculty member.
And our daughter graduated from Oregon State with a degree in psychology and no clue to what she wanted to do.
And she happened to talk to a naval recruiter on campus, and ended up going to naval officer candidate school after she graduated, and becoming an ensign.
And she did very well in the Navy, but she ended up secretly getting married to an enlisted man under her command.
And that was a no-no on the Navy, and when they found out they were both in trouble.
And again, making a long story short, they both left the Navy, and the Ann was in the reserve.
She got promoted in the reserve, so she was in good standing as far as the Navy was concerned.
But they had two children, and she was basically soccer mom until her two daughters were in college.
And she went back and got a degree as a paralegal assistant, so she was working in that field.
So both of our children are doing things.
They enjoy a great deal.
Each of them has two children who have done very well.
And so that's something that Kate and I can look at with some satisfaction also.